[Musique]
bonjour ma gym bon on est d'accord même
si les héros déchets elle fait mal quand
même là bas dit il
faut compenser par une séance de sport
avec vous alors il paraît qu'aujourd'hui
en plus pas besoin de matériel pas bon
se déplacer on fait ça tranquille chez
soi on fait ça à la maison sur et avec
ce que vous pouvez avoir chez vous donc
par exemple une chaise un canapé et un
escalier ok voilà vous avez tout ça chez
vous les habitants ni nommé ya
l'escalier
montré en place comme d'habitude trois
exercices tout à fait ça alors donc vous
allez pouvoir vous installez donc au
niveau de la chaise donc les mains
derrière votre dos la recherche de votre
buste donc les vins sur la chaise on va
bien comme ça ouais avant c'est un tout
petit peu les pieds donc là vous allez y
donc voilà les fessiers sont en devine
est en fait vous allez réfléchir au
niveau des bras descendre les fessiers
et avec la force de vos bras voilà
vraiment et je sais que catherine est
une grande elle va dire si c'est bien
normal mais demain les triceps ça va
être long c'est ça donc là vous faire
travailler tout à fait l'étude célèbre
combien enfin nous 500 semble bien
encore vous qui êtes si la sève à 50
bien on découpe en déposant d'épicerie
de 2 10 répétitions ce sera très bien
avec 30 secondes de
l'exercice pour faire travailler
maintenant les gens avant les cuisses
les fessiers donc là des squats vous
savez pas faire des squats c'est parfait
pour apprendre donc la largeur de votre
bassin pointe de pieds légèrement en
ouverture et là vous allez comme si vous
vouliez vous asseoir sur la chaise mais
je ne me séparais en fait je fais ici
obligation de vous remonter exactement
donc on inspire et on expire à la montée
voilà garder les genoux a légèrement en
ouverture et mettre une paire de talons
c'est un petit bain fait voilà chez nous
on fait du sport pieds nus alors la
voilà très bien voilà pour les squats et
notre dernier exercice donc là on a un
steak mais vous pouvez le faire chez
vous si vous avez des escaliers évoqué
le faire des montées et des descentes
d'escaliers elle est inutile donc je
sais dans quel sens nous montrer danses
slaves ok donc comme ça et donc je monte
je descends tout à fait cette fois c'est
adapté donc vous l'avez la jambe droite
y est tous les jours dès lors on répète
on se fait donc là où c'est ça donc si
vous avez je sais pas un état chez vous
que vous pouvez faire deux
allers-retours prendre une pause de 30
secondes deux allers retours on évite de
prendre l'ascenseur si on habite un
immeuble c'est mieux et coll voilà
directement tous rejoint voilà donc
trois petits exercices que vous pouvez
faire chez vous avec le matériel que
vous avez qu'on a à 10 plombier un robot
quand je m'arrêterai
pas tant la maligne parce que je sais
que ça peut devenir beaucoup plus
complet d'un moment en musique c'est
plus un panier est effectivement au bout
d'un moment
la travail pourquoi
pas un du tout aussi
bas merci
installés mais on est d'accord on évite
quand même de faire du sport en sandales
chez soi quoi oui
affaires de basket quand même au nom va
voir dans le
noir dans le placard à chaussures
merci beaucoup beaucoup marine
effectivement on a de quoi enfin on n'a
plus aucune excuse pour ne pas sortir de
chez soi ne pas faire de sport puisqu'il
ya tout à disposition chez soi je
renvoie vers les manip point fr qui est
qui et le site internet du de la salle
pour laquelle vous travaillez l'uci oui
notre chronique n'a jamais aussi bien
porté son nom aujourd'hui parce qu'on
vous fait vous échappez michel de sport
merci ça
et on part en vadrouille à l'égout